okay let's start with a really basic
stuff this is what Saturn looks like
it's the second largest planet in our
solar system the sixth furthest away
from the Sun it's predominantly made of
gas it as a nice big ring around it and
that is everything that I ever learned
about Saturn when I was in school not
very much it was a pretty good starting
point but when it comes to astronomy
personally I find that the closer you
look the more interesting stuff gets and
so here are my favorite things about
Saturn that I have learned since I
started teaching myself starting with
its moons Saturn has 62 of them
including what is probably the geekiest
moon in the entire solar system - which
is basically a naturally occurring Death
Star like from Star Wars but but real
and not only that but if you view the
moon again but with heat vision the
thing turns into friggin pac-man proof I
think that if there is a God he is a
massive nerd Saturn's most
scientifically relevant moon though is
probably Titan it's Saturn's biggest
moon and although it is much smaller
than Earth it is one of the closest
things we have ever found to our own
planet it has an atmosphere for one
thing but also in much the same way as
we have a water cycle here on earth
Titan has a methane cycle now here on
earth methane only exists as gas in fact
popularly it's known as one of the gases
that you could find in farts a Titan is
it the perfect temperature for methane
to not only exist as a gas but also as a
liquid and as a solid just like water
here on earth so on Titan it rains
liquid methane to form rivers and giant
lakes of the stuff now when it comes to
the planet itself Saturn the big gaseous
ball inside of those rings when compared
to its rings it sort of doesn't really
look like that much however the fact
that there actually isn't that much to
Saturn is one of the most interesting
things about it because although it is
massive it's about 10 times as big as
Earth is because it's mostly made of gas
it's actually the least dense planet in
the solar system which means it just
isn't very much stuff that makes it up
now what this means for the planet is
that because it also rotates incredibly
quickly much faster than I could do of
my hand
the whole thing is actually squashed by
about 10% which on that scale is insane
but even more crazier than that is the
fact that Saturn the planet is actually
less dense than water which means that
if you were to find
big enough swimming pool to put it in
satin would float it is a planet that
would flow on water like a friggin
planet size rubber ducky now Saturn's
rings were first observed just over 400
years ago by Galileo but due to the
technological limitations of the time
his telescope just wasn't quite good
enough they have to be able to work out
exactly what he was looking at it was a
bit blurry basically he made tons of
observations and drawings of them and
was just incredibly baffled remember
this is the first time that anyone had
ever seen a ring around a planet ever he
even once described the planet as having
ears it actually wasn't until after
Galileo had died when the rings were
first correctly identified by Christian
Huygens so Galileo never found out what
on earth he was looking at poor man
nowadays they were able to look at the
Rings much more closely most recently
with the Cassini spacecraft which is
currently in orbit around the planet we
know that not only is a ring system
incredibly intricately complicated but
it's actually made up of millions and
millions of blocks of ice which is by
the way the reason that we can even see
Saturn's rings from so far away because
the light from the Sun travels and hits
the ice in Saturn's rings and the ice
reflects that light back causing the
Rings to shine that's why we can see
Saturn's rings because they are
literally shiny now although there's no
current consensus on how the Rings
formed
why they're actually there one thing we
do know for certain about them is that
they are not going to be there forever
eventually they will just drift away
which is pretty sad sure but to me it
just makes it all the more special that
we are alive now at a time when we can
truly appreciate the Rings for what they
are and one of my personal favorite ways
to appreciate Saturn is with this photo
taken by the Cassini spacecraft of a
Saturn eclipse the Sun is directly
behind Saturn in this picture and it is
just that as well it's a picture a
photograph taken with an actual camera
in space that we can now look at it's
just so cool and if you need another
reason to love this photo even more you
see that little white speck there in the
background sort of looks like it could
be one of Saturn's moons that's earth
just happen to be caught in the
background of the picture that is earth
photo bobbing right there so there you
go that's everything I love about Saturn
the no wait then that's that's a case
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool